earth-shattering news that the wwe brand
was coming to peacock as well and just
last weekend
wrestlemania 37 in the spot where the
super bowl was played this year
raymond james stadium that went down on
peacock and to talk about it is not only
the wwe chief brand
officer but also along with triple h the
premiere
this sunday at 10 eastern time of a e on
a e wwe's most wanted treasures hosted
by
the chief brand officer of the wwe
stephanie mcmahon here on the rich
housing show how are you stephanie
i am excellent thank you how are you you
know what i'm i'm great i just will
always want to be buttoned up when i'm
i'm uh introducing a chief brand officer
i want to make sure i touched upon on
all the important
items did i get a you did you did that
was a
phenomenal introduction thank you i will
take that um
let me first first things first what's
your first wrestling memory
like growing up mcmahon what what give
me give me a good
memory of yours i mean my whole life is
you know really wrestling was a part of
it
but um you know one of my early memories
is the first live event that i ever went
to what's that
and you know i was in between three and
five you know i was pretty young
and i remember being backstage it was at
the philly spectrum
that doesn't exist anymore and
i remember seeing these kids like i was
in this the back hallway backstage
and all of a sudden you know my dad was
working my mom was working i was just
kind of you know nearby
and a group of kids came running down
the hall
screaming at the top of their lungs and
and are
clearly afraid and they ran past me and
then i looked to see
you know what they were afraid of and
here comes george the animal steel
which um you know he was bald for people
who don't know he had very hairy back
hairy
chest green tongue and he was you know
sort of lumbering
you know chasing the kids having fun
really um
scared me to death i screamed
i ran straight for my dad ran up his leg
buried my head in his shoulder
and he started to laugh and i thought it
was so weird because
my dad is my hero right kill anybody who
would you know
become you know potentially do harm to
me and he started to laugh
and he then turned and introduced me to
jim myers
aka george the animal steel and it was
my first sort of inkling into the world
of wwe so i guess that next question is
when did the wwe demand
its uh superstars wax their backs when
did that happen
i just you know wondered because you
don't see that too much that hasn't
happened i don't know if
you watch that closely wow do you have
any andre the giant memories do you get
any of that
stephanie yeah well you know i pretty
much uh grew up with andre
and i considered him you know one of my
best friends my mom used to call andre
my gulliver
and gosh i mean i used to play and he
broke his ankle i used to play in his
cast
because it was like the whole the size
of my whole body his ankle cast
i remember after wrestlemania won
you know that was really my father's
vision of how was i going to put wwe on
the map what was our super bowl
their emmys those are our grammys and he
came up with wrestlemania which was this
huge you know combination of of pop
culture and and sports entertainment
liberace opened the show with the rocket
um cindy lauper accompanied wendy
richter to the ring mr t
actually competed in the main event um
you know billy martin was a guest
timekeeper muhammad ali was the special
guest referee it really was
who and back then there was no such
thing as social media right
little did i know at the time that my
parents had mortgaged
everything that they owned to make
wrestlemania one happen
um i i certainly wouldn't have
understood what that meant at the time
so needless to say there was a big after
party at the rainbow room
and uh andre and i did not feel like
participating so we were sitting outside
and i kind of fell asleep on his lap and
and people magazine actually came and
took a picture
and my parents wouldn't put let them
identify who i was in the picture but so
it said andre the giant just slammed big
john
stud you know not the person on his lap
you know whatever the caption reads
so they mortgage the the future
to put wrestlemania one on your folks
that happens yeah they were that so my
parents always have a history of betting
on themselves
and um and that's exactly what they did
yeah they mortgaged
everything that you know that i'll say
we because
sure but that we collectively owned not
that i owned anything
no but that's your future you know well
yeah
you know wow so i did not know that
that's
and now here we are wrestlemania 37 in
the books on peacock you
you've got you know wwe literally
everywhere the number of platforms that
you have i can't even keep track
uh stephanie mcmahon here on the rich
eisen show so
you mentioned that you were uh that
andre the giants cast was large enough
for you to play and is that one of the
most wanted treasures
that's uh on this channel that's a great
question
it is not one of um this season's most
wanted treasures
um but you know it certainly could be
but i
i think i know where it is
what are the most wanted treasures that
uh you and triple h are going to start
searching for um that premieres this
sunday at 10 eastern on a
e stephanie absolutely and there there's
a few different ones and it's not just
us but it's also you know a cast of our
superstars and legends and you know it's
really cool to
hear their stories and their perceptions
um you know from these various moments
because you never realize
sometimes how much a physical object can
bring back a flood of emotions
um and it's really that nostalgia factor
it's like owning a piece of history it's
kind of the reverse nft right when you
own
this physical object it's like owning
that moment
um so it you know we have undertaker's
gear when he debuted um which is
you know really iconic in terms of you
know the
the undertaker character and everything
that that character came to mean
we have um speaking of andre we we go
looking for his passport as one of the
objects
and i actually didn't expect
even the thought of andre's passport to
make me emotional but it did
um it absolutely it just brought me to
tears
thinking about this man and everything
that he lived through
as a giant you know he had a acromeglia
which is um
a tumor on your pituitary and he
actually never stopped growing
um but you know he one of the reasons
that we bonded so much is i've always
just growing up you know in in the life
that i've had
i've which has been remarkable and i'm
very grateful
um for everything um but i've always
hated judgment you know people just
judging
other people for whatever reason and it
bothered me how some people would treat
andre
um like a freak you know like a sideshow
freak
some not not everybody you know a lot of
people he was revered and everything
else but
um i didn't like that and i asked him
one time and i was a little girl you
know i wasn't that old and i asked him
if it bothered him
and he just looked at me kind of
quizzically
and uh and and he said that it did
and it just really was the beginning of
you know
i mean our friendship had started before
that when i first met him i was really
little
uh my mom actually tells the story of he
came to our house and
uh we had a trampoline outside and he
walked over to the trampoline and put
his hand out
and i stepped in his hand and he brought
me up to his cheek and i kissed his
cheek
i don't remember that but my mom tells
that story and it's
uh it's pretty cool so yeah andre and i
go way back but so his passport you know
definitely brought back this
his flood of emotion for the man and and
everything he lived through
and the stories of the different
territories you know he
he grew up on a very small farm in uh in
france
and um went on to live this huge life
and
that life is sort of captured and where
he went in this passport so
that that's enough that's one of the
objects um kane's
original character uh you know
before he made his debut in in wwe
you know that costuming and gear which
when you hear the story behind it how
the undertaker actually discovered kane
glenn jacobs who is now the mayor of uh
knoxville county um you know and and you
hear that backstory of how
undertaker was you know in memphis i
think it was
and he was there doing a favor for a
local promotion whatever it was
and that's when he first met kane and
then that launches the whole
you know story of the undertaker in kane
and their whole backstory in wwe is that
they were half
brothers and um you know all kinds of
stuff so
there's just some really incredible
artifacts
um and memorabilia that has so much
meaning behind it um and hearing the
stories
from the mouths of the people who who
wore it or or who were closest to it
it's just really it's really fascinating
and it takes you on an unexpected ride
amazing that is all amazing stephanie
mcmahon
i guess you're the original princess
bride
essentially you know one of my favorite
movies of all time
yeah i mean like we just during your
your
your soliloquy and story about about
andre we we did put up the photograph of
you with these white leggings
sitting on his lap he's got a drink in
his hand and
you know uh i mean i have my saddle
shoes on yeah
that's it my terrible dorothy hamill
haircut
you know hey look this is this is your
life here on the rich eisen show
stephanie mcmahon here on the program uh
okay
i'm now gonna hand you off for a second
to the rich eisen show social media
grand maester and wwe
expert of the program tj jefferson who's
asked questions
you've asked of drew mcintyre right
bobby lashley the whole the whole
schmear go go for it correct the tj hey
steph how are you great to meet you
good how are you it's funny for rich to
call me a wwe expert when you were on
the phone with you
so you are at the show we can
you i'm sure are more of an expert in
the history than i am
okay well you know speaking of your your
age being three and five having those
early memories i think my earliest
memory goes back to 1980
um watching wrestling with my
grandfather so you know and the thing
about
yeah the thing about wrestling fans is
you almost almost always always have to
defend yourself right for being a
wrestling fan you never have to
defend yourself because you like the nba
or the nfl but it's always like i like
wrestling and people kind of look funny
but it's
you know it's been an obsession of mine
you know i just as easily as i can name
all these super bowl champions
i can name all the intercontinental
champions ever so you know
it's been a big part of my life but uh
so to ask you a question after all these
years to narrow it down to one is pretty
tough but
let's talk celebrities celebrities play
such a big part in wrestlemania
um and with the success of ronda rousey
and pat mcafee and bad bunny um
what celebrities are you hoping are
there any celebrities out there you have
your eye on any
female athletes that you want to bring
in to uh participate in
wwe absolutely um
you know from an athlete perspective i
would love to see the williams sisters
come in
either individually or together um
you know there there's there's so many
incredible female athletes out there
you know and male athletes that that i
would love to to bring into wwe
um from a celebrity standpoint
in addition to the ones we've already
worked with
um you know i i think it it could be
really cool to work with
cardi b you know she had a tweet that
she had put out
not that long ago which was in in
follow-up to a reference to her name on
the show
um i think she would just she's so
colorful herself
and she's so vivacious and full of life
i think she'd really
bring that you know even bring it up a
notch in wwe
i think she'd be awesome um i think that
you know um going a complete other
direction
uh matthew mcconaughey has been you know
really catching on in terms of wwe he
was
on monday night raw i believe it was raw
uh to promote his book green lights and
and he and drew had an interaction and
then that led to you know another
interaction on another platform and you
know it just seems like there's
opportunity there
um and there's so many young you know
influencers and gamers and
everything else i mean i i think that
wwe is just
it's this incredible world right it's
almost like the gaming world come to
life
it's just totally this fantasy with all
of these different
characters and backstories and we can
make anything
work um and uh so i think there's a lot
of
a lot of untapped celebrities and
influencers that i would love to
personally work with well i mean tj as
you just heard stephanie
um is is a die hard and he asked bobby
lashley to be part of the hurt business
and bobby what did you say well he said
you know
this is my personal time in this
conversation if you want to talk
business another time and you know
look i i i told him that this is the
business of my show
peacock is part of the business of the
wwe
you are the chief brand officer of
this organization he has no idea i can
go
top rope on him like this
what sort of influence what sort of
influence might you be able to bring to
get tj
part of the hurt business i mean i know
or is that his purse
bobby's personal brand and you can't be
part of it or what can we do here
like what what's the art of the
possibility we'll offline
okay but we'll talk offline and and
uh and we'll make something happen i'll
send a tweet to you
but you understand stephanie you
understand that you know
this platform and yours are a match made
in heaven in that regard too
you know i know you got pat mcafee now
and i love pat yeah that's right
pat is tonight he is dynamite i mean the
guy
is red hot and he is funny and he is a
great communicator and he's got a
he's got a loyal following and i
understand
somebody maybe like me might not in your
mind potentially
fit do you need an essayist of some sort
for absolutely have you seen how much
publicity we we
we turn out we we definitely need people
to tell our stories
yeah i need to have you involved i could
i could i could like wear a boa you
could call me dick eisen or something
like that i could come up with a persona
dangerous guy what do you you know what
do you think
dangerous right yeah and i love it right
rugged rich eisen i'm in you know it's
what i'm saying i'm just
it writes itself i'm shooting my shot
i'm going yolo right here with stephanie
mcmahon
i'm just saying you know we're all part
of the similar family right now let's
try it out is what i'm saying
that's right that's right you do sound
like my 14 year old daughter though yolo
i've got a 12 year old at home you know
i'm picking up on a lot of stuff so all
right i'm sure
i try no i'm trying to clearly right now
i mean i'm i'm i
i'm trying my best uh congrats on on the
show on a e
start it premieres this sunday uh wwe's
most wanted treasures let's do this on
the regular if you're up for it i i
i'd love to hear more of your stories
and just chit chat about everything
going on in your world that is
uh at the forefront of sports
entertainment so let's do it if you're
up for it
sounds great i'm in thank you appreciate
it that's stephanie mcmahon the wwe
chief brand officer who might have been
nice to me and tj
i think or she's genuinely intrigued we
just offered her a golden business
opportunity is all i'm saying
that was incredible that was awesome at
steph mcmahon on twitter at stephanie
mcmahon on instagram
and again she and triple h
on sunday 10 p.m eastern on a ine hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here